bei mir im Studio ist Andreas
heinemann-grüder konfliktforscher und
Politikwissenschaftler an der
Universität Bonn herzlichen Dank dass
Sie sich Zeit nehmen diesen Tag hier mit
uns einzuordnen wir haben die Rede
gehört und auffallend ist dass Putin in
keinem Wort
prigoshi direkt adressiert sondern er
spricht sozusagen zu den allgemeinen
Verrätern der Meuterei was steckt
dahinter ihrer Meinung nach
Putin hat er die ganze Zeit eigentlich
beide gegeneinander ausgespült also
scheuge den Verteidigungsminister auf
der anderen einen Seite und und prigos
in den Chef von der wagnergruppe auf der
anderen Seite konnte beide ständig unter
Druck setzen keiner durfte alleine
mächtig genug werden und jetzt kann er
diesen dieses lavieren nicht mehr weiter
praktizieren sondern er musste
Entscheidung treffen weil gregorien die
Machtfrage gestellt hat und jetzt hat er
sich auf die Seite sozusagen das
regulären Militärs gestellt aber es ist
ein bisschen wieder Zauberlehrling er
hat ja den Trigger ihn selber geschaffen
hat private Militärfirmen zugelassen das
heißt der staatliche Gewaltmonopol
aufgehoben und die verselbstständigen
sich nun sozusagen
Opfer seines eigenen seiner eigenen
Kreation geworden
ich denke er wird gewinnen er nimmt die
Situation sehr ernst Vergleich mit der
Oktoberrevolution 1917 gleichzeitig wird
eine neue Legende vorbereitet nämlich
das Durchstoß sozusagen vielleicht jetzt
für die Misserfolge an der Front
zuständig ist also nicht nur die Stärke
des Westens sondern eben auch der innere
Feind also da wird eine neue
Rechtfertigung sozusagen aufgebaut
die Frage ist ob damit die Konflikte die
ja zu dieser Zuspitzung geführt haben
eigentlich gelöst sind indem man jetzt
wahrscheinlich pregorian von Gericht
stellt die Frage ob man ob es dazu
überhaupt kommt oder ob er gleich
neutralisiert wird wie Putin sagt auf
jeden Fall ermittelt der russische
Geheimdienst gegen ihn sie haben eben
gesagt putin wird das Ganze gewinnen
jetzt da sie sind sie sicher also
also er wird nach einer Voraussicht nach
die
Konfrontation dieser beiden
gewaltapparate gewinnen und zwar bei
pregorian von der ganzen Logistik her
auch schon eine Vergangenheit immer von
dem regulären Militär Abhängen der kann
ja nicht eigene Ressourcen generieren
die Frage ist die ob es jetzt direkt zu
Schüssen von sozusagen russischen
Kämpfern
wagnergruppe auf Soldaten kommt das
heißt zu einer Art von militärischer
Auseinandersetzung das wollen viele
gerade in der Region Roßdorf am Don
verhindern weil russische Generäle ja
auch mit Wagner zusammengekämpft haben
und kein Interesse daran haben gegen
ihre früheren Waffenbrüder sozusagen
jetzt die die Waffe zu richten ich
glaube auch die Wagner Leute wollen
letztlich nicht mehr bewaffnete
Auseinandersetzung aber unterm Strich
wird Putin sich damit durchsetzen dass
er dass er sagt das Modell Wagner kommt
hier mit zu am Ende die Autonomie von
Wagner wird wird eingeschränkt weil das
ist Hochverrat und
das wird nicht mehr zugelassen also
diese alte Modell ausspielen beider
gegeneinander das kommt hier zum Ende
das heißt sie gehen auch nicht davon aus
dass ich eventuell andere noch prigoshi
anschließen also andere Truppen
vielleicht auch aus dem Militär selber
dass es dazu Überläufen kommt also es
hat einen Reihe anderer privater
Militärfirmen auch gegeben die jetzt
schon heute da über Telegramm Kanäle
mitgeteilt haben sie würden sich mit der
wagnergruppe und viel gosin solidarisch
erklären
grundsätzlich denke ich trotzdem dass
das eine Frage der Zeit ist bis
sozusagen der staatliche Gewaltapparat
sich da auch durchsetzt wie gesagt weil
die Ressourcen nicht eigenständig
generiert werden können die sind
abhängig aber
es ist so wenn man eine elitenspaltung
die daran sichtbar wird und auch eine
Spaltung über die Kriegsziele also es
hat einen größeren Hintergrund die sind
unsicher wofür kämpfen wir eigentlich
pregorian sagt dass die Kriegsziele sind
nicht mehr zu erreichen wir müssen die
minimieren wir müssen von diesem
maximalismus Weg wir können nicht mit
seinem Kampf bis zum Ende führen wird
wir dürfen auch mit dieser Dächern
Informationen nicht mehr weitermachen
mit dem Lügen der eigenen Bevölkerung
diese ganzen Themen die bleiben ja
unabhängig von pregorien bleiben die ja
da das heißt diese Sollbruchstellen die
sind von sozusagen zugespitzt worden
aber der Konflikt wäre nicht gelöst
indem man
rausnimmt und und entweder vor Gericht
stellt oder liquidiert ja vielen Dank
bis hierhin wir sprechen gleich noch mal
weiter wir schauen jetzt noch einmal auf
einen Statement von prigoshi in dem er
eben seine Handlungen heute noch mal
erklärt und sich eben offen gegen die
militärische Führung Russlands stellt
wir befinden uns im Stab der sonder für
Operationen für 7 Uhr 30 unter unserer
Kontrolle sind alle militärko Objekte in
Rostow darunter auch der Flughafen da
hat die Militärflugzeuge die an der
Frontlinie im Einsatz sind setzen ihre
Arbeit fort sowie auch die
sanitätsflugzeuge das einzige was wir
gemacht haben also die Kontrolle
übernommen damit die Militärflugzeuge
nicht uns sondern die Ukraine angreifen
die
Leitungsorgane der Streitkräfte der
Arbeit sind wie gewohnt die jeder
Offizier ist am Arbeitsplatz und wir
stören die Arbeit der Stadt nicht und
als
als wir hierher gekommen sind müssen wir
feststellen er norbertäteritorien sind
verloren worden enorm
Menschenmassen sind verloren worden um
mehrfach mehr als offiziell bekannt
gegeben wird die sanitätsverlust pro Tag
machen manchmal bis
1000 Menschen aus das sind die getöteten
die Verwundeten und die Verweigerer es
mangelt an Munition und es mangelt an
der Leitung die Menschen sind in der
gastgasse der Chef des Stabs ist
geflogen worden sofort erfahren hat dass
wir uns dem Gebäude nähern
so da haben wir noch mal
prigoshin gehört den Chef der
Söldnertruppe Wagner Herr Heinemann
Brüder sie sind weiterhin bei uns sie
haben eben gesagt das ist eigentlich für
Brio nicht zu gewinnen dieser Aktion
jetzt dann fragt man sich warum macht er
das trotzdem denn wie das für ihn
ausgehen könnte ist ja auch eigentlich
absehbar warum jetzt also es gab vorher
schon immer Kritik auch an an der
russischen Militärführung auch warum
jetzt dann also begründet wird es damit
dass das russische
Militär die Luftwaffe ein Angriff gegen
einen Wagner Lager geflogen hat und da
durch russische
Luftstreitkräfte eigene Wagner Soldaten
getötet worden sind das ist sozusagen
vielleicht die Provokation sogar von
tschuldigung gewesen das scheuburg
letztlich in diese Situation bringen
wollte wo er die Machtfrage stellt und
sagt so und dann werde ich als scheuburg
zusammen mit Putin diese
Auseinandersetzung gewinnen wenn er
darauf nicht reagiert hätte alles auf
seinen eigenen Kämpfer geschossen wird
dann wäre seine Autorität innerhalb der
wagnergruppe vollkommen untergraben
gewesen das heißt also er hat das
wahrscheinlich auch gesehen als als so
ein Punkt jetzt muss ich reagieren weil
sonst bricht mein ganzes Unternehmen
zusammen das zweite ist das reguläre
Militär hat eben auch immer Alternativen
zu Wagner aufgebaut also
mit dieser privaten militärfirma von von
Gazprom paar Turk aber auch andere die
dann eingesetzt worden sind das heißt
also die Monopolstellung die Wagner in
Zeitlang hatte insbesondere Bach Mut
Solidar die ist ersetzt worden das heißt
sein Geschäftsmodell war von daher auch
unter Druck geraten und das dritte er
hat erhebliche Verluste zu gewaltigen
gehabt die waren ja praktisch
Kanonenfutter sind auch zum Teil unter
Drogen gesetzt worden um da in die Front
reinzuziehen und so weiter sie Verluste
waren enorm und insofern konnte er sich
auch nicht mehr so regenerieren weil die
Rekrutierung die Wagner seit September
letzten Jahres in den
strafgefangenenlagern machte jetzt vom
regulären Militär in den
strafgefangenenlagern gemacht wird das
heißt also die Auffüllung der eigenen
Truppen bei Wagner ist erschwert weil
scheuge der Verteidigungsminister lässt
sich das Modell Wagner übernommen hat
interessant also auch dieses dieses
Spiel sozusagen zwischen Show und
prigoshi lassen sie uns noch mal auf den
äh Tschetschenen kadiro schauen wo stell
eigentlich immer Putin treu war jetzt in
der Vergangenheit das bleibt dabei
glauben sie oder ist das auch ein
Wackelkandidat wirklicher
also ein Wackelkandidat glaube ich eher
nicht weil er hängt ja auch ab letztlich
von von der Macht die im von Putin
zugeteilt worden ist es gab eine gewisse
Arbeitsteilung zwischen diesen
irregulären bewaffneten Gruppen wenn der
Ukraine die kaduro also die kaduro
Kämpfer waren eigentlich die Truppen
hinter der Front die verhindern sollten
das Leute diese Tieren das heißt die
waren wir im Zweiten Weltkrieg sondern
äh hintere Auffang Brigade die
wenn Leute jetzt von der Front geflohen
sind weil die Ukraine Fortschritte
gemacht haben und so weiter und dann
aufgegeben haben und da war für Waren
die kanüren zuständig letztlich nicht
gegen die Ukraine sondern gegen die
eigenen Leute die bereit sind zu
desitieren oder ein Rückzug zu machen
vorzugehen insofern
ein bisschen anderes Geschäftsmodell
früher waren natürlich die Leute da
schon vor dem Krieg auch so die
killertruppen die für innere und äußere
Operationen genutzt worden sind also so
um
Dissidenten umzubringen was sie in
Russland gemacht haben aber auch
Auftragsmorde im Ausland durchzuführen
inklusive Europäischer Union oder auch
Tiergarten mords in Berlin aber insofern
das Geschäftsfeld hat sich dazwischen
kadyroof und Wagner nicht sehr
überschnitten was bedeutet das ganze
jetzt für den Krieg in der Ukraine das
ist für die Ukraine jetzt ein günstiger
Moment weil sich der Fokus der
Aufmerksamkeit jetzt gerade woanders hin
richtet oder wie beurteilen Sie das
jetzt sie haben gewissen taktischen
Vorteil weil natürlich in Rostock am Don
durch die Besetzung dieses Kommandos in
Roßdorf am Don was zentral ist für
Kommunikation und und für die Sommer
Kommandostrukturen über über diese ganze
Frontlinie das wird die Russen sehr in
ihrer inneren Koordination behindern das
werden sie versuchen auszunutzen dass da
unklar ist wer ist jetzt eigentlich wie
wie gehen die Befehlsketten auf der
anderen Seite glaube ich
das pregorian Wagner zum Ausdruck
gebracht hat dieser Krieg ist eigentlich
in der Form nicht zu gewinnen also
dieser abnutzungskrieg muss irgendwie
beendet werden weil die Erfahrung oder
das was auch pregorian sagt wir können
diese Kriegsziele diese maximalen
Kriegsziele nicht mehr erreichen wir
müssen die minimieren wir müssen uns
vielleicht auf Don jetzt und Johannes
konzentrieren aber diese großen Ziele da
Kiew und endmilitarisierung und
Entnazifizierung und Regimewechsel und
dass sie die Bevölkerung unter Kontrolle
bringen da hat der keine
Illusionen darüber dass diese Leute
nicht mehr zu gewinnen sind selbst wenn
die Russisch sprechend oder ethnisch
russisch sind die sind für Russland
verloren und das anzuerkennen da gibt's
ja eine Fraktion die jetzt sagt wir
müssen raus aus dem Krieg und die andere
Fraktion die vielleicht jetzt gewonnen
hat in Folge dessen sie sagt wir kämpfen
mit Putin bis zum Ende insofern würde
ich sagen für die Ukraine taktischer
Gewinn aber strategisch könnte es noch
schlimmer werden weil die Fraktion die
für kriegsbegrenzung ist verloren hat